hey everyone what's up welcome to
another hd tutorial in this one i'll be
showing you how to make a youtube
playlist so um if you have visited my
channel before which you most likely
have if you have subscribed already i'm
gonna maximize this here i'm gonna
scroll down a little bit you can see i
have a number of playlists a laptop
battery savings series a 2009 apple
releases series and i'll keep updating
that with the next year in the next year
i have a free software series so i'm
going to show you guys how to make
another playlist or to create possibly
your first playlist of a certain batch
of your videos
um actually using youtube so we're going
to do is go to anything here such as um
like roll over your name and just maybe
just click uh click on playlists now
you're probably not going to have any
playlists here but this will still pop
up on the left hand side you'll see a
little drop down list we're actually
going to hover over new and hit the
playlist button and then down here we'll
actually be able to name our playlist so
i'll name it updates and on and inbox
and i've actually actually already
created the playlist it does take a few
seconds so here's the playlist i'll
click on it as you can see it's
completely empty
um there are a number of things you can
do to this playlist as well as adding
videos to it but basically we're going
to find a video that we want to add to
this unboxing i'm sorry this updates an
unboxing on inbox playlist sorry so i'm
just going to go to my videos again and
type in
update
and i'm going to find one of my update
videos here's update uh my very first
update was update 1.0 so i'm just going
to click on this
and pause it and you can see under the
new youtube layout is a little bit
different but you just see that playlist
button right there click the playlist
button and choose which playlist you
want to add it to as well as new
playlist i'm going to put it under the
inbox and updates one and just hit add
and the video has been added to your
playlist so we'll go through here and
find all my videos and uh all my update
videos
i believe there are four
and we can add them all to the um the
brand new playlist so here's the uh the
update 1.1 video i don't know why this
one has 900 views but here we go
playlists and again it'll be
automatically on the one you last added
a video to
so that's very good
and one two more times update
pardon me if i'm going a little bit fast
here but there's 2.0 and also inbox v1
or version 1. we're just going to add
that to the playlist here
and last but not least we have
um update
2.1 so here we go update 2.1 click on it
and just pause it and go ahead and add
that to the playlist so there we go
we've added all the videos to our
playlist now whenever you hover over
your name and go to playlists you will
see um if you click on that updates
playlist those are the four videos in
the playlist now a lot of people say
well why doesn't this show up on my
channel youtube does this thing where it
automatically like doesn't add certain
ones to my channel or does add certain
playlists to turn
playlists to your channel so just go
ahead and click on your name
and hit the edit channel button and from
here you can actually edit um the way
your videos show up so if you go to um
to channel design
uh there's a whole bunch of layout
properties here and you actually here
have playlists box now you'll notice it
by on the right hand side here's the
three playlists and here's the three
that we've selected you can have up to
three channel playlists so i'm just
going to remove the free software one
and add the updates one add and there we
go those are the three playlists that
will show up under my featured video to
save this uh configuration just hit the
update channel button at the very top
make sure you don't reset the values and
it says my channel has been successfully
updated so now let's go back to visit my
public channel again and there we go we
have a laptop battery saver that apple
releases and updates an inbox
now here's a cool thing you can do
underneath it there's actually a
description of the updates and inbox uh
tutorial uh not tutorial of the 2009
apple races releases it does actually
have a description of it if we do click
on this we can actually edit the
playlist um edit the playlist to change
uh the description underneath it so if
people happen to click on it then they
can chill in the playlist so let's go
and go under um playlists again
and here we'll find the updates and
unboxings and it says we can edit
playlist info just go ahead and expand
that and here we have a description box
so i'm going to pause this video and
type a description and come back to you
guys when i am done
alright i finished putting the
information here and all we're going to
do when we finish just hit the save
changes button and the playlist um
information has been changed so now
let's revisit our channel and we scroll
down here and there sure enough it'll
have here you'll find important
information etc and here's the four
videos that we've added to the playlist
so i hope you enjoyed this tutorial on
how to make a playlist in youtube there
are a lot more tutorials coming not only
about youtube but about um different
things you can do in the tech world in
the business on your computer etc so if
you do like these tutorials go ahead and
subscribe and if you do have a tutorial
idea or request just go ahead and
subscribe and send me a message and i'll
put it in my little mailbag document
right here i do have a ton of videos
left to do so um yeah keep me posted um
if you like what you see again subscribe
and i'll talk to you guys later peace